I was born in a very poor family I never
got a great education but sometimes you
have not only have to work how you have
to work smart I complain a lot when I
was young because I think Bill Gates
took odd opportunities for the Microsoft
Steve Jobs all these guys wanna soar get
a mentor what's that believe nation it's
Evan I believe in you and this channel
is designed to be part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best Jack Ma and some of
his best life-changing advice mentor me
jack
also if you want to know what Jack and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the people who did
the bottom should believe in the model
and I believe what I do
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
get used to rejections a lot of film I
feel for funny things that I filled a
key primary school tests for two times
and I filled three times for the middle
school group middle school you know for
three years I tried fill in the
universities
so I applied jobs for thirty times got
rejected
I went for a place you know you're not
good I went to either even the KFC when
KFC came to check up do I say you see 24
people went for the job
23 people accepted I was the only guy
and we went for please five people all
of them accepted I was the only guy than
I receive receive it so to me being
turned down rejected oh by the way I
told you that I would apply for Harvard
for ten times rejected I know sorry
there I think we have to get used to it
we're not that good even today we still
have a lot of people reject us I don't
think in this world a lot of people be
rejected more than 30 times if we you
know the only thing we never give up the
only thing like who like a forest to God
will keep on fighting we give unchanged
ourselves we don't complain whether you
are successful not successful I find a
130 people when they finish the job if
they make the mistake in the film if
they always completely
this guy would have come back if the guy
only check himself
yeah something while we've been here or
something want me there there this guy
has a hope rule number two prepare for
the future
people like me I was born in a very poor
family I never got a great education and
I failed all the examinations for what
reason I don't know but later I realize
I don't have money I don't have
technology I don't have a lot of good
backgrounds where we have a rich uncle
or something no they only that competed
with my people then young people is
let's compete for ten years later this
is what I believe ten years later will
be happening so everything I do for that
goal I know
ten years later this thing is going to
happen so prepare for that because I
know if I compete with him for next
Mouse no chance so this is how my
message is up it's a challenge but it's
opportunity and it's the opportunity for
people like us this world the most
difficult of thing is to convincing a
successful people wait tell him this is
a great opportunity to nananananana
forget it right I've been doing this for
30 years but for people like us we're
looking for opportunities in order to
survive so we will do anything to be
creative so this is the message 30 years
it's opportunity for us it's a challenge
for those people who are 60 years old if
they're 60 years old and not
discrimination but it is tough for them
rule number three work smart who works
harder the people at eBay are the people
of Alibaba
it's sometimes you have not only have to
work how you have to work smart mm-hmm
so would you say you work smarter than I
pay I'd have to say yes right well it's
so far yeah so so far okay because
because I think you know we are pretty
lucky people and the people see you yeah
you work very hard
chew in this or that so many people work
very hard but they're not that I told my
team when we I'd pill I asked a lot of
people sitting there I say you know all
of you guys motovlog I'm millionaires
and so rich but 15 years ago who are we
it's so difficult for us to hide people
fifteen years ago people who are not
that bad I said people can walk still
walk on sorry we hide them because
nobody believed internet Oh by belief
internet and they join a company those
people who believe they're smart they
were had hunted back to the other
company set up their own company those
people no nobody go to hell Huntingdon
this state today the successful very key
reasons we exist will persist we never
give up we believe the dreams together
rule number four see challenges as
opportunities in this world
today's of full of challenges and
opportunities 2,000 years ago full of
challenges and opportunities and I'm
sure 2,000 years later
full of challenges and opportunities
there's always it depends on how you
look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people say there's no
opportunity I complain a lot when I was
young because I think Bill Gates took
opportunities for the Microsoft Steve
Jobs all these guys there's no job up
there is no great big stuff left for us
but I think opportunity always lies in
the challenges always lies in the
complaints if you can solve the
challenge you have there you will be
successful
the big challenge you solve the big
problem of the big opportunity you have
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip is change
yourself when I stand in business it's
so difficult to be a small business
owner in China it should be five months
to 1 $500 as stupid no chance and it is
and I have no any idea about how to run
a business and I'm going to go to
register company called Internet the
register officer said no there's no such
word into the dictionary [ __ ]
register and Internet so we say we have
to register under the name say he was it
what's the name is a very consulting
firm and I have no idea that what is
computer
so my first company's pounds of hope
because computer concerning firm
it was tough was not knowing anything
but enough technology without knowing
anything but a computer in the past 15
years been working I call myself like a
blind man riding on the back of the
bright Tigers
those experts riding horses they all
fell we survived it was rewarded by the
future who believe the future we change
ourselves we never completely honest
what my heroes well I got my star in my
dream from America 15 years ago when I
came to America when I visited Silicon
Valley I saw sounding in the evening the
road it was full of cars all the
buildings socialize that's the passion
and I went at the the hero I had as
Forrest Gump 14 years ago when I watched
justice you know he's a fictional
character though you just like that guy
I'd be watching that movie for about ten
times every time I would have frustrate
I watch the movie and I watch movie
before I came here again were you for
coming to the New York because I want or
watch the movie again and telling me
that no matter whatever change you are
you and I'm still the guy 15 years ago
no I only earn $20 a mouth
today I can do that much you know the
little one would see ones full volume
yeah the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you that sums you
Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you like this video check out the one
I made on how billionaires think it's
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I advise students as much
as possible look for the job that you
would take if you didn't need a job I
mean in that don't sleepwalk through
life